après neuf mois de rénovation le gymnase
de coignières a rouvert depuis lundi
seulement le rez-de-chaussée l'ouverture
de la mezzanine est prévue pour le 14
octobre après le passage de la
commission de sécurité
on avait besoin en effet de la
rénovation de cet équipement aujourd'hui
les premières associations qui ont
visité les lieux sont ravis un faut dire
on le serait à moins c'est vraiment une
très très belle rénovation la quinzaine
d'enfants de l'association l'école des
sports a pu fouler en premier le sol
refait à neuf
très heureux depuis le temps qu'on
l'attend un petit nom il a des très
attendues par les utilisateurs et on est
très contentes de pouvoir ouvrir et les
enfants en priorité on est là qui
s'amusent bien déjà sur le nouveau
terrain qui est coloré très pratique
en plus des associations sportives les
écoles et les collèges pourront
également utiliser cet équipement
au total le montant des rénovations
atteindre 2 millions 56 mille euros un
budget qui a servi à installer un mur
d'escaladé avec plusieurs niveaux de
difficulté une salle de fitness et un
ascenseur pour l'accessibilité des
personnes à mobilité réduite
on a reflué intégralement les vestiaires
et les douches parce que ça ça
nécessitait on a refait le chauffage
intégralement
on a refait tout l'éclairage aujourd'hui
grâce à ces travaux qu'on a fait en
termes d'économie d'énergie
on va économiser à peu près 20%
d'énergie par rapport au gymnase
précédent donc c'est quand même là un
gain substantiel
les parents venus chercher leurs enfants
ce jour là ont pu constater les travaux
finis il est bien équipé
toutes les installations d'un des supers
gymnase on peut faire du handball du
futsal vraiment bien bien profité
l'inauguration officielle du gymnase est
prévue autour du 12 décembre et les
coigné rien sont invités à visiter
l'équipement